DEAL.
>> Sean: ABSOLUTELY.
I WILL GET TO THAT LATER IN
THE PROGRAM TONIGHT.
WELL SAID.
DR. GORKA, THANK YOU, DAN
BONGINO, THANK YOU.
JOINING US WITH MORE
REACTION HOST OF WAR STORIES
COLONEL OLIVER NORTH.
LET ME PICK UP WITH
DR. GORKA WAS SAYING.
IT'S INTERESTING TO WATCH
THE MEDIA REACTION TO THE
PRESIDENT AND NOT ONLY
WANTING FREE TRADE BUT ALSO
WANTING FAIR TRADE AND
SAYING THAT THERE HAS GOT TO
BE RECIPROCITY.
KNOWING THIS PRESIDENT AS
WELL AS I DO, YOU KNOW HIM
WELL, COLONEL NORTH.
HE'S THE CON SUE
HE'S THE CONSUUE
HE'S THE CONSUMMATE
NEGOTIATOR.
HE CANADA AND MEXICO EVERY
OTHER COUNTRY IS OPEN FOR
NEGOTIATION U THE WHOLE
THING IS OPEN FOR
NEGOTIATION.
SIMILARLY HERE.
HE OBVIOUSLY NEVER WANTED TO
GO TO WAR WITH NORTH KOREA.
BUT NOR WAS HE GOING TO GIVE
AN INCH TO KIM JONG UN AND
HIS DICTATORIAL PRACTICES
AND HIS INTIMIDATION AND HIS
SUPPOSED SHOW OF FORCE WITH
HIS MISSILE LAUNCHES.
>> SO, DO YOU SUPPOSE THAT
THERE IS A RAPID TRANSLATION
OF THE ART OF THE DEAL BEING
MADE IN THE KOREA RIGHT NOW?
I WOULD TELL YOU, THE
COMMENT MADE BY SENATOR
GRAHAM WAS SPOT ON.
IF HE THINKS THAT HE IS
GOING TO GO INTO THIS
CONVERSATION AND TRY TO PULL
SOMETHING OVER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S EYES OR HIS HEAD, HE
IS DEAD WRONG.
LOOK IT, HERE IS THE OTHER
PART OF THIS THAT NO ONE HAS
SEEN YET.
FOR OVER A DECADE, THE
IRANIANS HAVE BEEN PAYING
FOR THE NORTH KOREANS TO ACT
AS THEIR R AND D FACILITY SO
THAT THE DEAL THAT WAS DONE
ISN'T GOING TO SHOW
SOMEWHERE.
ISLAMIC REVOLUTIONARY GUARD
CORPS IS IN CHARGE OF THE
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION.
THE NUKES, THE ICBMS THE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS AND
BIOWEAPONS.
THEY HAVE BEEN FUNDING
SECRETLY FINANCIAL AND TECH
SUPPORT TO THE NORTH
KOREANS.
THIS IS GOING TO PUT THEM ON
THEIR BUTTS.
THE BOTTOM LINE OF IT IS, IF
THIS WORKS AND STILL A BIG
IF, IF THIS WORKS, IT IS
GOING TO MAKE THE ENTIRE
WORLD SAFER BECAUSE IT'S
JUST GOING TO STOP THE NORTH
KOREANS.
IT'S GOING TO STOP THE
IRANIANS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
GET AWAY WITH IT DOING IT AT
HOME EVEN UNDER THE
RIDICULOUS AGREEMENT THAT
WAS MADE IN VIENNA.
IT'S GOOD NEWS.
>> Sean: AS WELL AS ANYBODY,
YOU UNDERSTAND AND YOU SPENT
AN ENTIRE LIFE EITHER
INVOLVED FIGHTING ON THE
BATTLEFIELD, BEING WITH
TROOPS AND HEROES ON THE
BATTLEFIELD AND ALSO THE
WORK THAT YOU DID IN IRAN
WHEN YOU WERE HANDED BY YOUR
GOVERNMENT A SUICIDE PILL IN
CASE GOD FORBID THAT YOU HAD
TO TAKE IT.
I NEVER UNDERSTOOD THE
MENTALITY.
EVERYBODY PRAYS BARACK
OBAMA, HE WINS THE NOBEL
PEACE PRIZE, 150 BILLION IN
CASH AND OTHER CURRENCIES.
BILL CLINTON THOUGHT IT
WOULD WORK WITH NORTH KOREA
AND KIM JONG IL.
IT DIDN'T WORK.
HE STILL HAS NUCLEAR WEAPONS
AND WE GOT TO THE POINT
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE LEFT IN
AMERICA THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND YOU CANNOT BRIBE
A MURDERING DICTATOR RUSS
REGIME?
>> YEARS AGO YOU AND I WERE
ON THE RADIO TODAY TALKING
ABOUT MADELEINE ALBRIGHT
DOING THE MACARENA BECAUSE
OF THE DEAL THEY HAD DONE IN
1994.
THAT DEAL IS WHAT GOT THEM
TO THIS POINT TODAY THAT AND
THE HELP OF THE IRANIANS.
THIS ARRANGEMENT, IF THIS
WORKS, AND I PRAY THAT IT
DOES.
IT'S NOT ONLY GOING TO STOP
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
KOREAN PENINSULA, IT'S ALSO
GOING TO HAVE A VERY
POSITIVE EFFECT IN THE
MIDDLE EAST U THIS IS A
MAJOR SET BACK FOR THE
IRANIANS, THEY HAVE BEEN
USING THE ASSAD REGIME AND
THE NORTH KOREANS TO DO
THINGS THAT THE REST OF THE
WORLD IS LOOKING THE WRONG
WAY WHILE THE IRANIANS ARE
DOING IT.
THIS IS A MAJOR BLOW.
IRANIAN GOAL.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
SANCTIONS CONTINUE.
THE JOINT EXERCISES
CONTINUE.
YOU HAVE A PROMISE BEFORE
MAY THAT AT LEAST FROM NOW
UNTIL MAY IS NOT GOING TO BE
FIRING ANY MISSILES OR TEST
FIRING THEM.
WHAT ELSE THE DOWNSIDE?
I DON'T SEE ONE.
>> THE DOWNSIDE IS THAT THIS
GUY COMES FROM A FAMILY LINE
THAT DOES NOTHING BUT LIE.
THEY HAVE LIED REPEATEDLY
NOW FOR DECADES ABOUT WHAT
THEY ARE DOING AND WHAT THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO DO.
>> Sean: THE MINUTE THEY
LIE, THE MINUTE THE DEAL IS
TAKEN OFF THE TABLE.
>> UNDERSTOOD.
HOPEFULLY HE WILL UNDERSTAND
THAT.  THAT'S WHY THAT
LITTLE LIGHT-HEARTED COMMENT
ABOUT ART OF THE DEAL.
IF THIS GUY UNDERSTANDS WHAT
HE IS UP AGAINST, AND
SITTING DOWN AT A TABLE
SOMEWHERE IN THE WORLD
OPPOSITE DONALD TRUMP, HE
HAD BETTER MEAN IT WHEN HE
IS SAYING I'M GOING TO
DEKNACK
DENUACK
DENUKEK
DENUKE COLLAR RISE.
TRUST BUT VERIFY AND YOU ARE
NEVER GOING TO GET A GOOD
DEAL OUT OF THE PRESS.
YOU CAN COUNT ON IT.